okay there is sort of an impeachment
hearing against Donald Trump that has
started and I really thought long and
hard about how to approach this story
and the first sort of question we have
to ask is is this really an impeachment
hearing that has started within the
House Judiciary Committee and my sense
is that it's not that this is being
called a quote impeachment hearing but I
don't actually think that that is the
right name for it this is a hearing
which depending on what happens in some
abstract sense could lead to an actual
impeachment inquiry and this is already
if you're saying David that sounds
muddled this is why I think that this is
extraordinarily problem a problematic I
try to tell you things as I see them
truly without over or understating the
importance of something and the way that
this has gone down so far is seeming to
me like a self-destructive waste of time
and I'll explain why so yesterday the
House Judiciary Committee had a hearing
they started interviewing Donald Trump's
former campaign manager Corey
Lewandowski Corey Lewandowski gave
Democrats nothing and in fact he
generated some really good sound bites
that right-wing media and Donald Trump
are absolutely gushing about he
stonewalled
he brought a letter with him from the
White House lawyer Pat Cipollini saying
that executive privilege has been
invoked now there's an obvious question
about wait a second Corey Lewandowski
was the campaign manager meaning Donald
Trump was not president at the time that
he was instructing Corey Lewandowski to
do things could executive privilege
really even be asserted given that Trump
wasn't president at the time it's a
question that would have to be fought
out legally and we don't have an answer
to that in the immediate he refused to
answer questions about conversations
with Donald Trump like a very well
behaved tool of Donald Trump and Trump
praising him for it and in the end this
to me was a pointless waste of time
gongshow this was going to be the way it
went down from day one Lewandowski even
before the executive privilege letter
was written and presented
said that he was looking forward to
defending Donald Trump in these hearings
they were never going to get anything
from Lewandowski so then the question
became in not getting anything from
Lewandowski can Democrats make him and
by extension Donald Trump look bad
enough look guilty enough to further the
arguments of impeachment and a real bona
fide impeachment inquiry and I've said
before the whole point of an impeachment
inquiry if one were to be done would not
really be to remove Donald Trump via
impeachment because it's not gonna
happen a Republican Senate is not going
to convict Donald Trump on the basis of
what's happened so far certainly not
before the November of 2020 election the
whole point in my view of an impeachment
inquiry would be to publicize the
content of the Moller report what's in
the Muller report is devastating to
Trump most of the public has not read
the Moller report so you do the
impeachment inquiry to get the content
of the Moller report out there at front
and center it distracts from Trump's
campaigning it may send Trump into a
frenzy on Twitter where he may end up
further self-incriminating the only
interesting thing that came out of this
hearing that could be advantageous to
Democrats is that Corey Lewandowski
refused to say whether Donald Trump
preemptively offered him a pardon it's
very interesting ultimately I don't
think that's going to go anywhere we
already know colloquially informally
that Donald Trump is in police
implicitly dangled pardons in front of
people and it has had absolutely no
consequences so I think that this
ultimately is a mistake I believe that
if you are really going to do a proper
impeachment inquiry you do it you very
clearly label it as such and it is an
impeachment investigation this is a sort
of we've got some Democrats saying they
believe Trump is impeachable but this is
just a hearing to talk to people which
depending on what they say could become
a full-blown impeachment inquiry or
attempt to impeach I've said before I'm
fine with an impeachment inquiry if
we're gonna do it I'm fine with saying
we're not going to do the impeachment
inquiry let's just focus on removing
Donald Trump electoral II in November of
2020 I'm fine with it either way but
this offhanded
hearing of something that could sort of
de facto be an investigation into
whether there should be impeachment vote
the guy out in 2020 and remove him and
if you look at the media coverage over
the last 24 hours of this right-wing
media is doing what we know they were
going to do they are going to say this
is a partisan witch hunt Corey
Lewandowski went in there
he gave them nothing Trump's happening
it Trump's happy with it it unites the
right around we're not going to let
Democrats pull this off and then on the
Left you hear Democrats saying
Lewandowski stonewalling he's not
answering questions etc but this is what
they've been doing all along there is no
additional benefit to this so it's I'm
calling this a half-hearted pseudo
impeachment maybe hearing where
witnesses will say nothing I don't know
what type of PR they expect to get
that's beneficial to the cause of
removing Donald Trump but it is seeming
to me very miscalculated now I'm willing
to have my mind changed if you saw this
and you thought yeah this is good this
is going to help us achieve something
let me know what that is and how it's
going to help achieve it as you know I
just call things what they are and this
is the way this looks to me let me know
what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman and the show is on twitter at
david pakman show and make sure you're
also following me on twitch at twitch.tv
slash David Pakman four live streams
happening weekly I want to tell you
about one of our sponsors called the
Menlo Club a men's fashion community
that provides carefully curated style
packages for any type of guy and they're
giving you as a David Pakman show viewer
your first box for $35 off when you
click the link underneath this video or
go to their site and use the promo code
Pakman as a member of the Menlo Club you
receive delivered right to your door a
hand-picked apparel package that follows
the seasons latest trends based on your
own unique style profile I hate shopping
for clothes it's always been a pain to
go to a store figure out what to buy and
that's why the Menlo Club is so perfect
for me all I had to do was fill out a
quiz on their website so they could
learn my sizes and style preferences and
I received clothes that perfectly fit my
own personal style so far I've really
enjoyed what they've sent me all of
their clothing is designed by their team
in Los Angeles
each box features items from their own
in-house fashion brands five for
everyday wear New Republic Footwear and
Grande see athleisure wear in every box
they send you you get a minimum of two
items often more every box is different
shipping is always free and they let you
exchange what you get if it doesn't fit
you can pause or cancel your
subscription at any time right now I am
on their monthly subscription for 60
bucks a month but they also offer a
seasonal subscription where they send
you a box of clothing every three months
for just 75 bucks but regardless of
which option you choose they are giving
everyone in our audience $35 off their
first box to redeem your $35 discount
just click the link under this video or
go to their website and use the promo
code Pakman at checkout